Mila Kunis steps out with a bold new
look and reveals a shocking new details
about how she and ashton kutcher first
hooked up everything it's funny
et caught up with the star Monday night
in New York at a special fan screening
of her movie bad moms the pregnant star
was rocking a chic faux bob and gushing
all about her one-year-old baby girl
Wyatt she's actually really good
travellish because you get you get used
to it like kids you know it's app to
their environment and um she's pretty
awesome it just taking like one or two
days to adapt to it the time difference
I would say but uh she got on Passport
she's got a couple stamps in it then at
Tuesday morning at me lifted up the
Howard Stern Show and got super candid
about how she and her hubby first got
together I don't even if I'm supposed to
sell it sure if I'm getting I might get
in trouble for this because it's today
well whatever so here's how this
happened yeah we oddly both did a movie
called
I did friends and benefits he did a
movie called no-strings-attached yeah if
we just paid attention to these movies
we should know that like this does not
work out in real life
never well we clearly didn't pay
attention that was super private from
very French that's the three months
later yes I was like this isn't funny
right do in other words you became
exclusive to one another will always
open that we were incredibly open with
one another in regards to like where we
were with our field that's when it works
yeah